[Music]
foreign
professor of Statistics at Monash
University in Australia probably at the
posit conference this year leading a
workshop on Tidy time series and
forecasting using our
It's relatively common for organizations
to collect huge amounts of data over
time
and then find that their existing time
series analysis tools are not always
suitable to handle the scale the
frequency and the structure of the data
that have been collected
for example you might collect the Ali
data but the regular classes in base R
aren't designed for that
we might have a lot of Time series but
again Base hours really designed for
single series or small numbers of series
you might have time series stored in a
data frame or a table
but then the modeling tools aren't set
up for time series models
in this Workshop we're going to look at
some packages and methods that have been
developed to handle the analysis of
large collections of Time series
in a tidy verse Style
it'll be a two-day workshop and on day
one we will talk about time series
analysis using these tools we'll look at
the tibble data structure for flexibly
managing collections of related time
series we'll look at how to do data
wrangling data visualizations and
exploratory data analysis we'll explore
feature-based methods to explore time
series data in high dimensions
a feature-based approach can be used to
identify anomalous time series within a
collection of Time series
or to Cluster or classify Time series
primary packages for day one will be the
tibble package lubridate and feasts
along with the Tidy verse of course
day two will be about forecasting we'll
look at some classical time series
models and how they are automated in the
Fable package
and we'll look at Ensemble forecasts and
hybrid forecasts
and also best practices for evaluating
forecast accuracy
finally we will look at forecast
reconciliation allowing millions of Time
series to be forecast in a relatively
short time while accounting for
constraints on how the series are
related to each other
I'm looking forward to it and I hope to
see you there
[Music]